The tumor board met last week and suggested doing three rounds for nine weeks of chemotherapy
to debulk the next two years before fluid radiation in the fall. She suggested these three
medications, these three chemotherapy drugs. She said it will be harsh, especially the five FU
because that's a combination one. It will cause mouse sores along with other terrible side effects.
Well, at least they're being honest with you. Or you could use these three still using the five FU
or you could use these three. We did discuss these so I don't know what the side effects do.
You know you have any thoughts about these. We've had patients that have used all sorts of different
combination chemotherapies. I cannot tell people legally or even morally and ethically that
chemotherapies know the right thing to do because we've had people literally I think saved their
life take doing some chemotherapy. So and the other thing is even if we had 10 people that did this
combination for whatever type of cancer, even if it was the exact same type of cancer that you have
it's still not going to be telling how you're going to respond the positives or negative
response that any single person will have to that same combination of drugs just because your
body reacts so differently than everything else. I would say this and I said this you know
dozens of times in the past if you're going to choose to do chemotherapy you've got to have a
positive outlook on it. Can't be all down to the dumps you can't be all sad about it because
you want to go okay I'm choosing to do this. God is leading me to do this. I am going to you know
believe in my heart that God's going to use this to kill the cancer and knock this down. If you go
into any type of protocol they keep I feel like I'm losing and I feel like I you know doing something
I don't want to do and as you go and you agree to do it because you feel like it's your only option.
I just don't think you're going to have as good a result. I think there's a lot of evidence
that support, that comment that I just made and I just don't think that's the right way to do it.
I mean if you really really honestly feel so negatively and I'm not talking about the person
who wrote this I'm just talking in general anybody if anybody feels so negatively about people
there but don't do it until you feel like you have permission to do it. Have a good attitude about
anything that you choose to do. Know that God is going to protect you in all those things
that he's going to have his hand on you and yeah you're going to do some things like we talked about
last week about fasting for 24 hours before the IV and then going off your your um
anti-oxidants for 48 hours post chemo and then going and hitting hard with antioxidants and going
foot baths on a daily basis to pull that stuff out of your body and trust that God's going to
protect you through this and he's going to use this. So I know people have asked me personally how
Ann's son AJ who had leukemia, how he's doing. I just spoke with her text back and forth yesterday
the day before again just to recheck with her again. He's doing fantastic. He did do the chemo
and I am convinced if he wouldn't have done the chemo he would have passed away. His cancer was just
just went bunkers rampant and he was on death's door before it was all figured out. So
just you know God can use anything he can use chemo to heal you so you know just have that attitude
that if God is leading you towards doing chemo or radiation or surgery or whatever it is
um you know just you know doesn't mean you go in there blindly and you're going to do it because
you're you know you're making a foolish decision but be praying about it and trusting that his
hand is going to be in it and you're going to be protected through it. So other part of this question
I can't tell you which combination is better. I can't tell you if I do that answer nobody knows
that answer manufacturer of colleges to say they don't know that answer. This is just their protocols
that they followed and the only reason why they have this protocol versus putting everybody on this
is because some people will start on their primary protocol and they'll get sick and they'll think
that you know they react negatively towards something and it was they'll switch out of one of the
products so that it's just good practice of medicine so that's why they have you know different
protocols because some people have allergies towards different drugs too.